last year was obviously the 50th
anniversary of Doctor Who and the
biggest surprise that probably was night
of the doctor with Paul McGann returning
he obviously a big part of that how was
it for you just being a part of that
absolutely amazing I wasn't expecting it
and I didn't audition for it so we just
gave it to me which was out of this
world amazing Paul as well because it's
just a nice guy really that's good to
hear because others say it was a massive
surprise but since then it was what like
six minutes forty seconds long or
something like that it's such a huge
part of the kind of the Canon now and
the history that fans are petitioning to
have it made into like a spinoff series
I think 15,000 people have signed a
petition to make it serious would you
like to come back for that hell yeah
Edwards am I allowed to say that in a
heartbeat
it was just just the most fun to do and
the good thing about that suit obviously
as well that I know that castles have
died but you know the time travel and
they don't actually definitively say
that she's definitely density you never
know yeah no definitely as you say they
can they can do also send dr. who
so obviously you didn't get on very well
with the doctor in the show you're quite
mean to him I'd say how do you think
that relationship could develop down the
line if there was a spinoff and I think
ultimately she just needs to see that
he's you know the good dog she's only
just met him and she has just come from
the world that's just been torn apart by
by the Time Lords and their various
antics I kind of did a little bit of
research on that just so that I knew
just how you know seriously impacting
the time war was just because her sort
of disgust and fear was so tangible in
the script that I thought well I have to
make that real I have to make that about
something which is being through myself
more witness so yeah just have a look at
some old apps and ultimately I think as
we just have to
see the doctor being himself to be doing
what he does and then she probably goes
guys
amazing he said he's on he's on the
human side he's on everyone's side he
wants you know she she just didn't have
time to make that cool the ship was
crashing ship oh I'm not getting into it
any kind of TARDIS with the murderer you
say you've been researching gods who
there's a hell of a lot to research it's
hard to catch up on anything we've got
to there's so much history but you
actually even got to before is that
right a couple of years back tell us
about that upon how it was different
that time well I I wish in for dr. ken
but sort of strangely I was in the room
with lots of different people men women
all different ages and shapes and sizes
and we were all up saying part which is
mind boggling confusing I thought I
wonder what they wanted you know but I
just went in there gave it some welly
and and that was just that wasn't last
I'd actually not seen all that much
Doctor Who beforehand I'd seen a bit and
I used to watch and Tom Baker when I was
very very small and Davidson and
and then I saw a couple EPS rosetta
stone and David Allen see I just
enhanced in any of mass action for that
point which is sort of good actually
because I think I would have been a bit
in all of him was so terrifically
brilliant I think I would have been a
slightly so he was a total stranger to
me when I met him and he's just lots of
fun to work with there's so much energy
so many ideas and I was really quite
inspired watching him work and it's fun
it was a great crew that day Arthur's is
here today it's lovely you know and and
Frankie's hilarious he plays my uncle
Barry Barry I actually knew her evolved
because she's friends with Amanda Redman
who runs a theatre school that I used to
be part of she night drank a bottle of
wine once when I was like my early
twenties I remember I wonder why
yeah no she's great and alex is taking
lovely
they're all just lovely lovely people
funding so you say Matt Smith's office
he's such a livewire he really made the
doctor his own as all doctors have Peter
Capaldi's got big shoes to 70 now what
do you think he might bring different to
the role how do you think he'll be as
the doctor I expect instantly brilliant
I mean I've been glued in the thick of
it for the last Donner's how long and I
just think this is terrific actor
and I'm really excited to see what he's
going to bring to it I think I think
he's going to be very different from the
rest of them venue maybe yes definitely
Celia more serious she can lead us to go
that direction young and just so
wonderfully florid with Matt's
much energy and we just needed to have
this move into this next phase as I
suppose with every life that goes along
every regeneration you're still the same
however many hundred years old here so
you get older even though the body gets
maybe younger old or whatever depending
on the regeneration spirit gets long all
the time so it kind of works really well
but they went older with this this one
so I think it's very much speaking to
you I'll let you go on now I really hope
they do you make that spin up and I look
forward to seeing you again in dr. Haney
hopefully
you